[monitor beeping steadily]
[thunder booming]
- HI, YOU MUST BE LIAM.
- HEY, BUDDY,
HOW ARE YOU FEELING TODAY?
- [hoarsely]
I'M FEELING FINE, DR. GUPTA.
JUST FINE.
- THIS IS MARION GLASS,
AND SHE'S FROM
THE MAKE A WISH FOUNDATION.
- MARION GLASS.
- HOW ARE YOU
FEELING TODAY, LIAM?
- I'M FINE, MARION GLASS.
- GOOD.
WELL, I HAVE SOME NEWS
THAT MIGHT MAKE YOU FEEL
A LITTLE BETTER, HUH?
WE AT THE MAKE A WISH FOUNDATION
MAKE DREAMS COME TRUE
FOR LITTLE BOYS AND LITTLE GIRLS
WHO ARE VERY SICK JUST LIKE YOU.
- THERE ARE NO CHILDREN
LIKE ME, MARION GLASS.
- OH, OF COURSE NOT.
YOU'RE ONE OF A KIND,
BUT WE'RE GONNA MAKE ANY DREAM
COME TRUE
THAT YOU COULD EVER HAVE, OKAY?
- ANYTHING?
- THAT'S RIGHT, BUDDY.
THAT'S RIGHT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PLAY WITH
YOUR FAVORITE BASKETBALL TEAM?
WHAT ABOUT BE SUPERMAN
FOR A DAY?
- I WISH TO DROWN A MAN.
[eerie music]
♪
- WHAT?
- TO DROWN A MAN IN THE BATHTUB.
TO HOLD HIM DOWN
WHILE THE LAST BREATH
ESCAPES HIS BODY,
AND THEN BATHE IN THAT WATER,
ALL THE WHILE SINGING,
♪ LA-LA, LA-LA
♪ LA-LA, LA
- LIAM.
- YOU SAID ANYTHING.
- WELL, S-SURELY WE DON'T WANT
TO HURT OTHER PEOPLE,
NOW, DO WE, KIDDO?
[both laugh uneasily]
ANYTHING ELSE?
FLY IN A HOT AIR BALLOON
OR MEET A CELEBRITY?
- MY NEW WISH IS TO LEAN OVER
THE BODY OF A DYING MAN
AND PUT MY LIPS ON HIS,
STEALING HIS LAST BREATH.
[inhales]
- LIAM.
- NO ONE WILL GET HURT.
- ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE YOU--
- I WISH TO TAKE
ALL THE PROSTHETIC LEGS
IN THE HOSPITAL
AND BIND THEM TOGETHER
WITH THE DRIED FLESH
OF THE DEAD
INTO A WEBBED MASSIVE CREATURE,
AND--
- LIAM!
I AM SO SORRY, MS. GLASS.
- IT'S ALL RIGHT.
HE--HE DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT HE'S SAYING.
- I WISH TO PEE
IN YOUR MOUTH.
- WHAT?
- BOTH OF YOU.
- MINE?
- ESPECIALLY YOU.
- OH.
- I WISH TO PEE
IN BOTH OF YOUR MOUTHS
AS I STAND OVER YOU.
I'LL NEED A GLASS OF WATER
IN TEN MINUTES.
- ENOUGH,
YOU LITTLE SHIT!
- DR. GUPTA!
- NO.
YOU ARE REPREHENSIBLE.
YOU ARE EVIL.
YOU ARE A DEVIL CHILD.
- [whimpering]
- DR. GUPTA,
HE'S NOT A DEVIL CHILD.
HE'S JUST A CHILD.
YOU HAVE NO BUSINESS WORKING
IN A PEDIATRIC WARD.
- WHAT?
- I'M GONNA REPORT YOU.
- [crying]
[door slams]
- ♪ SHAME ON YOU, GUPTA
♪ SHAME ON YOU, GUPTA
YOU REALLY UPSET
MARION GLASS.
- THIS IS INSANE.
YOU'VE MADE ME QUESTION
EVERYTHING THAT I'VE EVER
BELIEVED ABOUT THE
ESSENTIAL GOODNESS OF CHILDREN.
- WISH GRANTED.
[flatlining]
- [gasps]
- [giggles]
I AM DYING THOUGH.
[flatlining]